fast bitte einmal für uns zusammen was
genau sich jetzt also ändert für alle
urlauber ja das wichtigste ist dass die
strategie von der die bundesregierung
spricht wieder geändert wurde innerhalb
nur kurzer zeit der minister begründet
das damit dass er sagt na ja man hat
eine regelung für die urlaubssaison
getroffen und jetzt wo die urlaubssaison
eben zu ende geht da kann man dann auch
bestimmte änderungen wieder in dieser
strategie zu lassen
tatsächlich ist diese strategie werden
dass gerade schon gehört in weiten
teilen nicht aufgegangen bisher also was
ändert sich es ändert sich vieles massiv
für reise rückkehrer aus risikogebieten
bisher bestand dort die tests pflicht
aber diese massentest diese corona
massentest könnten die
gesundheitsbehörden bei uns in
deutschland bisher überhaupt nicht
bewältigen deswegen wird dort erheblich
daran geschraubt das heißt wer jetzt aus
risikogebieten zurückkehrt aus dem
urlaub der muss in quarantäne bleiben
nämlich so lange bis er dann nachdem er
sich beim gesundheitsamt gemeldet hat
fünf tage frühestens nach seiner reise
einen eigenen negativen corona test
nachweisen kann dann kann er aus dieser
quarantäne raus dann kann er diese
quarantäne verlassen vorher nicht vorher
bleiben dann 14 tage
das ist verpflichtend jetzt geht es
darum ich habe den minister gerade
gefragt wie setzt der staat diese
quarantäne pflicht eigentlich um eine
rechte idee gibt es dazu nicht denn das
würde ja wieder die gesundheitsämter
massiv überfordern dh der minister sagt
na ja es wurde ja bisher
stichprobenartig gemacht und das wird
dann eben in zukunft auch
stichprobenartig gemacht also die
reiserückkehrer haben eine quarantäne
schlecht keine testpflicht mehr
sie können sich testen lassen fünf tage
nach der reise reicht ein negativer
corona test um dann wieder an den
arbeitsplatz zurückzukehren um die
quarantäne zu verlassen und das ganze
wird stichprobenartig überprüft seitens
der gesundheitsämter was ganz wichtig
war
der minister hat noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen dass es ja eine meldepflicht
gibt die bisher auch nicht recht
durchgesetzt wird an die sich viele
deutsche auch nicht halten die aus
risikogebieten zurückkommen die sollen
eben einmal aufzeigen beim
gesundheitsamt und sollen sagen 'ja ja
also ich komme aus paris oder ich komme
aus mallorca zurück damit sie dann eben
sich freiwillig daran halten
können in der quarantäne zu bleiben so
ist das im moment warum wird diese
strategie geändert ja weil man jetzt
richtung herbst vor allen dingen wieder
ein fokus auf die krankenhäuser auf die
pflegeheim errichten möchte man möchte
für das personal dort für das
pflegepersonal des klinischen personal
die test kapazitäten vorhalten denn die
sind in vielen vielen bundesländern
total erschöpft durch diese massentests
von urlaubern und deswegen eben muss der
gesundheitsminister jetzt diese
strategie wieder verändern als es die
testpflicht gab es diese eingeführt
worden sind war eines der großen themen
wer bezahlt das eigentlich alles du hast
jetzt gerade schon gesagt man muss jetzt
einen eigenen test vorlegen heißt es
auch ab jetzt muss jeder wieder für sein
gewohntes selber zahlen
davon ist auszugehen es wird darüber
nochmal morgen gespräche im kreis der
ministerpräsidenten der länder mit der
kanzlerin und dem kanzleramtschef und
dem gesundheitsminister geben davon ist
auszugehen dass heißt es gibt diese
tests pflicht dann ja de facto nicht
mehr
man braucht aber ein test um eben
innerhalb dieser 14 tage die quarantäne
zu verlassen das heißt viele werden sich
testen lassen wollen damit sie sich
nicht zuhause 14 tage lang ein schließen
müssen und den davon ist auszugehen wird
man dann bezahlen müssen auch das ist
neu